[Musik]
doch auch zur basta also mein name ist
khan herzlich willkommen wir heute zu
einem neuen video sind deine blätter
nicht heute 11 11 fakten vor die ihr
eigentlich gar nicht wissen wollt also
die sind ein bisschen ekelhaft ein
bisschen verstörend aber vorher gibt es
noch eine wichtige sache
auf diesen tag haben wir zwei drei
monate hingearbeitet sie haben so viel
zu
wir haben so viel herzblut in diese
ganze geschichte gestiegene freie minute
habe ich irgendwie damit verbracht die
neue gedanken zu machen neue designs zu
entwerfen so viele roben telefonieren
probieren wegen der besseren qualität
mit neuartigen drucken ezb und jetzt ist
es endlich soweit ich habe das video
hochgeladen hat es am ersten 12 16 uhr
online kommen und ich denke die meisten
von euch werden schon wissen häufig
hinausgehen
vs
jetzt muss ich alles auf premierminister
von de ich will da gar nicht allzuviel
jetzt sagen es ist halt nur ein kleines
baby was sie von grund auf ihnen die
großgezogen habe und die luga schon bei
auf die letzten 52 stunden offline aber
jetzt gerade es entweder online und ihr
könnt sachen bestellen und euch die
neuen produkte angucken manche produkte
wie beispielsweise die bettwäsche haben
eine etwas längere lieferzeit die
teilweise echt zwei drei vier wochen
betragen kann aber das findet ihr alles
im shop eingeblendet mit den
informationen und in den beschreibungen
zu den produkten und noch eine ganz
kurze sache danach komme ich zu den elf
fakten die ich euch vorstellen wollten
wir alle diesen bekommt auch instagram
der heißt nämlich shop von luca uns war
es mein account und dort werde ich eure
bilder hochladen wenn ihr merchandise
von mir also verlinkt einfach erschöpft
von luca auf eurem hochgeladenen bild
mitmenschen als aus dem lukas shop und
vielleicht werde ich dann euer bild auf
dieser seite teilen aber com mehr zu den
fakten früher verwendeten römer das
gehirn von mäusen als zahnpasta ja was
für dummköpfe die frau des inhabers von
der website match.com also das ist doch
ein dating website wie parship oder so
hat ihren mann verlassen weil sie einen
neuen mann auf der website match.com
gefunden hat es ist so ironisch alter
wenn eskimo babys erkältet sind saugen
die mütter den schlamm aus ihren nasen
damit die wieder gesund werden und ich
weiß dass man die nicht mehr eskimos
nennt aber mir fällt gerade andere
begriff für dich ein tut man halt ein
flog an das 350 fache seiner körperlänge
springen
das wäre bei einem menschen so wie wenn
er über den ganzen fußball platz fünf
könnte bei einem kurs tauschen zwei
menschen
mehr als 40.000 parasiten und 250
bakterien miteinander aus also wenn ihr
krank seid küste riss niemanden aus ihr
wollt nicht wie dem erzeugen wir
menschen haben so viel eisen in unserem
kompletten körper dass man damit einen
fünf zentimeter nagel herstellen kann
man alle von euch die vielleicht daran
gedacht haben ja ich gebe ihnen jetzt
mal lotto ich brauche ein bisschen geld
die chance ist höher das ihr von einem
umfallenden getränkeautomaten getötet
werdet als einen sechser im lotto zu
erreichen
lasst die finger von glücksspielen und
besucht wie bei den täglich auf den
scharfen die neuen produkt das in der
hammer im durchschnitt trennen sich
jedes vierte pärchen nach einem
gemeinsamen urlaub und dabei sollte im
urlaub doch eigentlich alles schöner
machen schildkröten können durch ihren
hintern atmen
okay ich bin ich raus ich war oben
können schildkröten durch ihren hintern
atmen
ich meine dass mit der schildkröte ist
natürlich schon eine krasse sache aber
es gibt in england einen sport der heißt
verrät lee ging und dabei muss man ein
frettchen so lange wie möglich in seiner
hose halten
ich würde am liebsten wieder den raum
verlassen
der gewinner ist der der am längsten
schafft ein frechen in seiner hose zu
halten und da gibt es auch ein paar
regeln wie beispielsweise dass man
selber keinen alkohol oder drogenkonsum
vorher haben sollte das treppchen auch
nicht man darf keine unterwäsche an
und das frettchen muss noch alle zähne
besetzen
gott ich weiß welchem sportlich nie
machen möchte heutzutage nehmen wir
menschen alle zwei minuten mehr bilder
auch als die gesamte menschheit
inkompetenten neunzehnten jahrhundert
alter es ist so krank
das was ihr vom video meine damen und
herren ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
getan ich mich machen
[Musik]
ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr mal den
luca schoppel suchen würde
dort könnt ihr unter anderem dieses
wetter nie mit diesem kretz miley trend
in diesem oliv euro strom auch kaufen
gefällt mir selber am besten von allen
produkten im neuen shop und des pop
socket finde ich auch hammer aber dass
genug von mir
ich wünsche euch einen schönen tag
schönen ersten dezember in your life